just me or does Oscar winner Jennifer
Lawrence always seem to have a big movie
coming out just in time for awards show
season that is how you do it everybody
but this movie is nothing like she's
ever done before and only we are joining
j-law and Chris Pratt on the Space Age
set of passengers so what it was a
beautiful experience because we all were
so passionate about it
well there is Chris and Jennifer falling
in a pool this is the kind of movie that
is gonna blow you away but here's the
setup a spaceship on a hundred and
twenty year journey to another planet
the passengers in hibernation but
Jennifer and Chris wake up too early 90
years to earth we will arrive in
approximately 90 years what it's all
what would you do
it's a conversation starter well what
would you do stuck on a spaceship one
mile long and five stories high with
several decades on your hands if you're
Chris and Jayla you fall in love Wow
you clean up pretty good yourself Chris
Pratt is the hardest-working person I've
ever met in my life I know you mean
another main character in passengers is
the Avalon itself designed like a luxury
cruise liner when I see the sets that
the people on this crew have built I
mean you can't help but be in awe huge
sets for the Grand Concourse the
observation deck and the like occupied 8
sound stages in Atlanta one at 40,000
square feet as big as a Walmart partner
mode there's even a dance studio and
those actors shrouded in green the
dancers and the waiters will eventually
be replaced with computer-generated
characters what can I get for you as for
the Android bartender Arthur played by
Michael Sheen
he's half-and-half very nice Arthur is
like a cross between a puppy and a
toaster
ever wonder what a pool of water is like
in zero-gravity morning
gravity failure j-law finds out it
becomes really clear that there's
something very wrong with the ship and
the gravity starts to go out the robots
are all failing Jim and I are at a race
against the clock to figure out what is
wrong with the ship and how we can fix
it
morning not just to save our lives but
the lives of the 5,000 people who are on
the ship
you